ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
elden ring has gotten its first major
update which is really exciting because
there were a lot a lot of things broken
in this game and a lot of those things
they addressed and fixed now if you're
new to from software games who are the
developers of elden ring when they nerf
stuff
they nerf it into the earth like it is
gone it's basically no longer usable now
i doubt they're gonna do that in elden
ring because they don't want an uproar
for it being broken in two different
ways it being too good and now it being
too bad they're likely going to balance
it all out there were a lot of bug fixes
there was a lot of balance updates and
then there were the major updates we are
going to focus on the more important
ones but if you want the entire list of
everything that was changed in the
update i will leave a link down in the
description so the first major change
they included in this latest update is
they added additional elements to the
game they added a new npc called jar bar
that's really cool i i've never seen
that before besides it being uh in other
games it would be dlc where we'd see
that kind of stuff but they just added a
new npc i don't know if they just forgot
to add this guy in originally or they
didn't have him done or specced out
before the launch date but that's really
interesting hopefully that's a that's a
common thing in this game i would love
to go out and find new npcs now you're
probably wondering like man dude i gotta
do an entire new play through to go to
this npc or maybe you were thinking
before that i never can find where the
npcs are i saw them one time and never
saw them again well this is another
major change that they made they added a
function to record an icon and the name
of an npc on the map when you encounter
that npc so this means when you interact
with an npc in the game you can see
where they've gone to so you could
venture off and find the next part of
their questline which is very strange
for from software to do i've always kind
of liked the kind of hidden aspect of
the npcs where you have to really know
where you're going but obviously they're
trying to make this game as accessible
as they possibly can to all these new
players 12 million plus players that are
playing this game now which is
incredible they're trying to make it as
accessible as possible without losing
that dark souls from software charm
while also making it a lot easier and
again accessible for all those new
players i absolutely love that i think
they're killing it with this game so
they added new quest phases for the
following npcs dielos nefeli liu kenneth
heights and gatekeeper gotstuck uh
several these people have never met so
that's interesting i'm gonna have to do
my fourth playthrough at this point to
go find all these people i wonder if
they just didn't have them done yet or
they forgot who who knows man but i'm
glad they're doing all this within like
the first month that's really really
reassuring to me that they they're gonna
update this game a lot and i'm okay with
that the next big one is they added
night background music to some open
field areas that sick i'll take more
good music i'm never gonna deny that
thank you next we've got some balance
updates to the pve and the pvp aspect of
the game so if you guys didn't know
there have been speedrunners just
absolutely annihilating this game using
two different things they've been using
horfrost stomp which does an absurd
amount of damage without having to get
right in front of the enemy it has a
wide range of motion
oh yeah yep they made it way slower to
use
way slower i mean i could spam this
before i literally could spam this and i
can't now that's definitely not going to
be as good now but that's what speed
runners were using to just burst through
the game like 30 less than 30 minutes i
think is the world record right now like
28 something but for all remembrances
there's been an issue with the sword of
knight and flame it's this completely
overpowered weapon that if you scale it
high enough it does an absurd amount of
damage so they said they decreased the
weapon skill sword of knight in flames
overall damage that's definitely a good
change it definitely needed to be nerfed
i don't know how hard it got nerfed but
let me know down in the comments the
other overpowered thing in this game was
the mimic tier where you can summon a
literal clone of yourself and at times i
thought that mimic was stronger than i
was because he could take a full blow
from a in-game boss and a little bit of
his health would go down and i'd be
pretty much dead if i got hit by that
the mimic didn't do as much damage as me
but i mean geez dude like if you can
just tank everything and then get those
ashes of war off like that's definitely
opie so in the update they decreased the
damage of spirit summons when using the
item mimic tier ash and they changed the
spirit's behavior pattern i'm assuming
they just made it weaker they changed
its behaviors i bet it doesn't do as
much as it used to do i bet it dies a
lot quicker now just like everything
with from software they're very vague so
we're gonna have to do a lot of testing
to see exactly what it does but in your
playthroughs you will notice that change
they fix the bug when you're riding on
torrent and he'll randomly disappear and
you'll float in the air that was a
hilarious bug that was all over the
internet for a couple weeks it happened
to me twice i think in about 100 hours
of the game so it wasn't that prevalent
but it was funny when it happened so
that's a nice change thank you for
fixing that so in these speed runs they
would combine the horfrost stomp with an
ash of war called determination of royal
night's resolve this was supposed to
apply a damage buff to the weapon you
use the ash of war on but players found
if you just use this ash of war and then
switch to the horror frost stomp it
would do
triple the damage the horror frost knob
already did which was already a lot
while spamming it i mean they could kill
bosses in like a minute or less it was
it was super crazy super overpowered
again it was kind of fun but you know we
can't have fun in these games man you
kidding me dude no it was it definitely
needed to be nerfed i was using the
horfrost stop on this frost character
that i'm making and even the base
horfrost stomp was extremely overpowered
so i would like to see it nerf down a
little bit hopefully it's not too much
and the last thing i see on the balance
sheet with the balance changes is they
increase the drop rate of smithing
stones for some enemies i think that's
great i've always had way more somber
smithing stones than i have smithing
stones so i could do as many upgrades as
i wanted to like smithing stone somber
smithy zone four through like nine if i
really wanted to but then i would have
this like i would have no normal
smithing stones so it seems like they've
spread them out across more enemies in
the game that was definitely needed
because you need more normal smithing
stones than you do somber so adding more
of those is fantastic they also added
some smithing stones to some early game
shopping lines i'm assuming from
merchants so if you want to just go buy
them from merchants that's also an
option to you it seemed like all these
changes from from software were
definitely needed this this was a w this
update was a definite w it's really good
to see from software get on this stuff
really quick because in the past they've
taken a long time and when they did do
it they nerfed it into the earth and it
would never be seen again so it's really
good to see them do this quick and do it
in a more balanced fashion than they
have in the past so i hope you guys
enjoyed the video again if you want the
full update sheet i'm gonna leave it
down in the description thank you so
much for watching the video and i will
see you all in the next one peace and
love